from changes to the Avengers lineup to a
new guardians of the galaxy movie and a
whole bunch of potential new villains
here are some of the major changes that
we can expect to see as the Marvel
Cinematic Universe moves past endgame
interphase for one of the biggest
question marks surrounding the end of
phase 3 has been who will be left
standing after the story of the Infinity
stones wraps up while a comic-book
character story can go on basically
forever the situation is different when
those characters are played by real
people actors have contracts and
contracts of expiration dates most of
the original Avengers lineup is facing
the end of their deals of Marvel as of
Avengers endgame whether it's through
heroic death or well-earned retirement
our time of some of these characters is
coming to an end but that said the odds
of losing all six original Avengers in a
single film is kinda inconceivable
especially since we know Black Widow is
getting her own movie but it's pretty
likely that we'll be saying farewell to
some familiar faces as the saga of the
Infinity stones come to a close and the
next era of the MCU takes off things
used to feel so simple and now
everything is about to change we're in
the endgame
Captain Marvel dominated the box office
in 2019 but the flying photon blasting
fighter pilots raising the stakes and
what the MC use heroes are capable of on
screen her solo film has also laid the
foundation for a Serie C super-powered
future while the movie left.if Carol
Danvers out in space on her own
adventures it's clear that Danvers will
be joining up with the earthbound
Avengers for endgame and it's aftermath
don't just take our word for it
Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige has said
that Captain Marvel is quote about to
take the lead and be at the forefront of
the entire cinematic universe he's also
confirmed that she'll be arriving to the
series as his most powerful character at
least for a little while
much like the actors who came before her
in the series brie Larson has reportedly
signed a seven picture deal with Marvel
so we can count on seeing a lot more of
the new Cubs in all the way through
phase four and maybe even beyond I like
this one
infinity war and endgame are two of the
biggest movies in cinematic history so
it makes sense that phase four is
kicking off of a slightly more grounded
story arriving just a few months after
the fourth Avengers movie is spider-man
far from home a second full-fledged solo
movie for the webslinger and the MCU
according to producers the film will
bring Peter back down to earth after his
experience with the Avengers with the
high schooler attempting a return to
normal life as Kevin Feige put it he is
quote-unquote a normal person lives a
normal life with a normal environment
who you know got these powers and who is
exposed to these extraordinary things
while the MCU will probably ramp up to
another Thanos size threat eventually
it's starting things up with a narrower
scope one of the high points of MCU
phase 3 was a wildly successful arrival
of black panther sure he made a handful
of appearances in Captain America Civil
War but the Charla's first solo film
turned heads won Oscars and broke
records like a panther also came out
just months before infinity war hit
theaters with the Condor playing a key
role in the movie's climactic battle -
even though - Charla met a temporary end
during the finale it's not surprising
that he's being confirmed as coming back
for a sequel wall no dates been set yet
for black panther - odds are that
wakanda's best will show up again pretty
quickly after endgame has ended from the
small-scale springboard of the first
Ironman the MCU has become a pretty big
place with giant personalities to March
we've already met cosmic entities like
ego the Living Planet the Kree supreme
intelligence and everyone's favorite mad
Titan but how about more cosmic good
guys it's time to meet a new team and
phase 4 the Eternals rumors of a film
about the Eternals gained steam in April
of 2018 just in time for infinity war to
make universe shattering power the new
normal while spider-man and black
panther may help keep things grounded
the Eternals are sure to help keep a
focus on the MCU cosmic side the arrival
of the god-like characters also has the
potential to set the stage for some
staggeringly powerful heroes and
villains as the MCU proceeds in December
2017 news broke that Disney would be
absorbing large portions of Fox in a
historic 8-digit merger if you're not a
fan of the Disney monopoly that's bad
news
but for Marvel Studios fans the
development is exciting
with huge implications for the
characters we
see in the MCU now that Disney has
officially gained access to Fox's
intellectual property they also got the
film rights to several of the company's
most famous characters including the
Fantastic Four the Silver Surfer
Deadpool and the x-men it's something
that Marvel fans have been clamoring for
for years Kevin Feige included having
access to all of the characters is
something I've been dreaming about for
my almost 20 years at Marvel many Marvel
fans will tell you that guardians of the
galaxy is one of the best things to ever
happen to the MCU but the future of the
franchise has thrown into doubt when
writer director James Gunn was abruptly
fired in mid 2018 the situation played
out in the public eye with actors and
fans venting their anger over the firing
and Disney digging in its heels it was
eventually confirmed that gun script
would be used for the postponed third
installments finally in March 2019
Disney relented and rehired Gunn to
finish what he started even better it
was reported that the studio never met
with or considered any replacement
director now that guns back in the pilot
seat a series is officially back on
track for volume 3 Marvel's phase 4
isn't just changing the face of the
movies it's also revamping the TV side
of the MCU story in late 2019 Disney
will be launching a new streaming
service at Disney Plus which promises to
be a major destination for fans of
Marvel properties it's been reported
that the service will host multiple
limited series centering around specific
characters like vision and Scarlet Witch
Falcon in the Winter Soldier and the
seemingly and kilovolt Loki but don't
write these offers cheap spin-offs all
characters will be played by their
actors from the film's with big budgets
to match the impact the shows have on
the MCU is likely to be far greater than
what we've seen from series like agents
of shield or the Marvel shows on Netflix
and like those loosely connected series
Kevin Feige has made it clear that the
Disney Plus shows will be essential to
the MCU directly impacting the movies in
ways we haven't seen before so if you
thought you didn't need to pay for
another streaming service think again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite MCU films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a
one
[Music]